okay good morning everybody and welcome
to this mid Suffolk District Council
Licensing subcommittee the committees
have been called to hear an application
to very a premises license for the the
cafe at Broad Street in I fight they're
just going to move on to be the agenda
that the procedure would be fairly
simple it will start with the licensing
officer given an outline of the
application if there's any questions
based on on that short presentation
you'll be entitled to ask questions the
members may also have questions as well
following that it will then be your
opportunity to give your statement and
present your case to the members to
decide they will obviously have some
questions for you usually there will be
objectors here but there are none so
what would normally happen is they would
then have an opportunity to to make
their objections so the the members will
be working on the the written
representations that have been received
from the objectors here but obviously
you can address any issues that you have
regarding those and then it will be a
quick summing up you will have the last
sight as the applicant the the members
will then go into a private session and
it will just be that the three
subcommittee members and myself as legal
adviser we also have councillor Phillips
at the back he's here as a reserve
member but with your permission he will
stay and listen to the private
deliberations if you're happy with that
I can assure you I will not take part in
the decision-making process this just as
a training exercise for for councillor
Phillips okay so moving on to items on
the agenda
I need a nomination for that the chair
for this thank you Guthries that you
okay
okay up to you thank you very much
indeed I've got to remember how to press
a button on myself welcome to this li
ting of the licensing subcommittee it
will be broadcast live to YouTube and
will be capable of repeated viewing the
entirety of the meeting will be filmed
except for confidential or exempt items
if you attend the meeting in person you
will be deemed to have consented to
being filmed and the images and sound
recordings could be used for webcasting
or training purposes the council members
of the public and the press may record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting when the public and press our
law are not lawfully excluded now first
of all remind you of some domestic
arrangements toilets are situated on the
other side of the corridor water is
available outside the room if the fire
alarm sounds please leave the building
immediately via the fire exit and make
your way to the assembly point which is
the Ipswich Town football ground follow
the signs directing you to the fire
exits at each end of the floor do not
enter the atrium the ground-floor area
and walkways if you are in the atrium at
the time of the alarm follow the signs
to the nearest fire exit use the stairs
and not the lives do not re-enter the
building until you are told it is safe
to do so please switch off all mobile
phones or turn them to silent so
apologies for absence and to receive any
declarations of interest by members so I
need to introduce everybody my name is
Cathy Guthrie and I'm the chairman today
we have councillor Dave Muller and
councillor penny option and we are the
three people making the decision today
we also have as you first met Nigel de
Loup who's our legal adviser we have our
licensing officer case Sanders and also
Catherine green and we have committee
officer thank you sorry why didn't they
put it here and I know you from old I do
apologize so if you'd like to introduce
yourself and I'm sure you'll remember
each other where I forget partners so at
cafe and bar 14 and I was the one who
put the application fruit I'm John
summers just here it was support 20
years ago I had licences embarrassed and
in the City of London you know because I
have a bit of experience that Janice
fairly new with mainland for me a little
bit so that's basically support
summers John summers
so can I call you Cat Cat is it Jim can
I call you Jim thank you so can you
confirm that you've received all the
copies of the relevant papers that we'll
be discussing today you have so we move
on to you just a check you will be
presenting your case your cell phone
yeah that's fine so is there any
property in here today who wish to
withdraw their application or
representation and that'll be yourself
do you wish to withdraw anything
no thank you so to the licensing officer
have there been any requests from the
parties for permission to call witnesses
thank you and half the parties indicated
they wish to present documentary
material yes we received a letter on the
24th of February unfortunately that was
after the end of the consultation date
and they have requested pathetically
accepted today well I've had legal
advice on this
and as the gentleman's here to present
and support and it was Iraq did arrive
late I don't think we can include the
late paper but obviously you're here
yourselves so that will be acceptable
thank you so do you know how long you're
likely to tell us about your case
and so okay how long do you think that
your case will be just read your report
that's fine so that's fine
so would you like to summarize the
matter under consideration please thank
you Joe this hearing is to determine an
application made to vary a plumber's
license made under Section 34 of the
licensing Act 2003 for Gerald Blue in
relation to the premise of cafe 14 Broad
Street I the application was received by
the licensing authority on the 9th of
January 2020 20 and a copy of this is
attached to this report as Appendix B
the application made has been subject to
the statutory consultation period as
prescribed by regulation the notices of
advertising the application have been on
display at the premise and published in
the press the dis Express on the 17th of
January 2020 the variation seeks to
alter the existing premise license this
is to amend the hours for sale and
supply of alcohol for consumption on the
premises to Monday to Sunday 12:00 12:00
o'clock midday 2 0 0 30 and the opening
hours of the premise to 8 o'clock to is
0 100 hours cafe has benefitted from a
premise license issued by mid Suffolk
District Council since the 10th of July
2018 a copy of the promise current
premises including the license plan are
attached to this report as appendix a
hearing is necessary to determine the
application following receipt of
relevant representations the license and
authority must carry out its potent
functions under the Act with a view to
promoting the licensing objectives which
are the prevention of crime and disorder
Public Safety prevention of public
nuisance and the protection of children
from harm in carrying out its licensing
functions the licensing authority must
have regard to his statement of licence
and policy published under Section 5 of
the Act and any guidance issued by the
Secretary of State and
section 182 where revisions are made to
the legislation or guidance issued by
the Secretary of State there may be a
period of time when the local statement
of licensing policy is inconsistent with
these revisions in these circumstances
the licensing authority will have regard
and give appropriate weight to the
relevant changes guidance and also its
own statement of license and policy the
subcommittee will also be aware of the
Human Rights Act 1998 considerations
specifically article 6 for the applicant
and articles 8 and 1 of protocol 1 for
those raising representations when
determining applications for the grant
license subcommittee must having must
having regard to the representations
made take such steps if any as it
considers appropriate for the promotion
of the licensing objectives to grant the
license subject to conditions which are
consistent with the operating schedule
accompanying an application modified to
such extent that the Authority considers
appropriate for promotion of the license
licensing objectives and subject to any
mandatory conditions which must be
included in the license or to reject the
whole or part of the application for
these purposes conditions of the license
are modified if any of them are altered
or omitted or any new condition is added
any party aggrieved by the decision
taken by the license authority and
respect to this application has a
statutory right of appeal to the
magistrate's court
thank you chair thank you do you have
any questions for the officer I have a
question and have you we see the the
complaints at the back have you been out
to the site to observe the site at all
and why it's chair Licensing done a
joint visit where the moment protection
on September 13th after 2300 hours
the reason the raise of the visit was we
received a complaint regarding noise and
possible breaches of license conditions
and can you amplify on the possible
breach of conditions what that might be
yes sir we did enter the building after
2300 hours people were then being
decanted from the building but there
were still a few few people sitting
upstairs Environment Protection officer
asked to see the till roll it was found
that money was being taken which people
running a tab
I think the applicant was not aware that
this was not permitted so we explained
what was permitted what was not
permitted and a subsequent warning
letter from Environment Protection was
sent to the premise license holder just
explaining the findings of the visit and
what he must do
thank you members do you have any
further questions of the officer no
thank you
would you now like to present your case
please thank you I mean we're us as cafe
we're here to be an asset to the to the
community we'll gnarly to the community
but also visitors and I believe that
where we are pursuing that with our
service that our level of service and
also our variation in our service on
multiple occasions we we get customers
come in and say are they feel like that
they're abroad because it's such a
unique unique business that we do
operate then in order to further provide
that service to our customers we did
apply for a variation in our license so
our opening hours from 11:00 to 1:00 and
our alcohol service hours from 10 p.m.
to half-past twelve after midnight I
believe that if we are granted then we
again we will be able to offer it to our
customers and grow within the community
we have we have a phone line available
which if any nuisance is to be made for
whatever reason then they can call our
number and then we'll be on call
immediately we have been open just over
a year last year the Valentine's Day was
our opening night then since that day we
haven't had any complaints personally no
one has come and complained there were
no phone calls and the police haven't
been invited for whatever reason
whatsoever and that's us
not to add something else to that to
assist junior unsub said I have 75 years
of age my wife is three years younger
than me and we don't pop all that off we
do pop down there sometimes after dinner
for a drink and I wouldn't support
somebody that I didn't think it was I
don't lake noise for starters and so I
wouldn't want to be in a situation where
there was too much noise as I said I had
extensive licenses in the seventies and
the eighties in London obviously
religious of the Scotland Yard and
enjoying a very good relationship with
both the police and the licensing
authorities and so I'm cognizant of you
know the responsibilities that go with
it and so I wouldn't be a support is
something that I didn't think was a
hundred percent in my opinion these
people are very professional in their
outlook and the way they are under
business and I can say that because I
once had an establishment when I had 42
people employed and so I've got
considerable experience for dealing with
the public and with staff and in my
opinion these people are very
professional but young but they're
learning and I don't believe any
mistakes they would make they would make
twice that's why I'm eloping thank you
thank you very much so penny do you have
a question please yeah a couple of
questions about your cafe terrace this
is could I just ask I presume there are
there is some kind of fencing around it
what sort of lighting would you have up
there and would you be having any sort
of heating I know a lot of places have
those gas heaters anything like that
could you just you know it's kind of
describe how you would set out the roof
terrace currently it's illuminated
there's a LED light by either end of
there's it's covered by two walls and so
the corner it has two sides which are
the walls of the building and the other
two sites which are the stores the seats
there's LED lights on both of the walls
and also the hallway leading to the
terrace it's glass so the light from the
hallway
shines onto the terrace regarding
heating we we have we've done and we're
not thinking of having any form of
heating there the one thing VI is having
an oversized umbrella so when it does
get rainy then we'll obviously put
deploy the umbrella you don't think
maybe you know in that we don't have
very good weather all the time in this
country that you might feel your
customers might want to ask for some
sort of because sometimes those
umbrellas actually happy
heating inside them don't they regarding
that we fought that again because of the
noise we don't really want people to to
want to go in that particular area we're
more of a lounge where you sit inside
and then then you have
your cocktails that was not really sure
how to word it but we don't really want
to make it all that inviting to to want
to go I feel as if if a heater was to be
cut up then it would be a problem might
arise from
just on that point if I may just jump in
because it's a similar point I noticed
there's an exhaust up there for the
odors from presumably the kitchen is
that quite noisy or whereabouts is that
located it's located on the rear of the
building that looks towards cross street
and again during the hours which the
cafe is open it's not open the bar we
don't open the bar I mean the cafe
opening hours are from half past 8:00 in
the morning until 4:00 p.m. and then we
open the bar from 6:00 until 11:00 last
night colleague but just one other thing
on that do people go up onto the terrace
to smoke and does it overlook gardens of
the neighbors yes the primary reason
that customers go there is to smoke it's
known as a smoking area does that
overlook customers no it doesn't
overlook any particular guidance it
doesn't look over the roof of next door
which I believe isn't occupied but
that's the extent of the view for the
moment I lost my colleague to continue
with the questions if I know please Jim
that as you'd be aware for the papers
there have been some objections
regarding noise etc but you did mention
in your sort of comments that you
actually have a dedicated telephone line
that people can phone you how often do
people actually make complaints about
the noise us personally through our
number we haven't received any right and
again that the phone is located on the
bar so if it was nearing we would be
able to see it yeah as one of the owners
of the business would you actually deal
with any complaints yourself or would
that be passed on to members staff to
deal with that would be myself you're
directly involved okay thank you for the
question and so I'm sort of coming back
to what was asked earlier is what
exactly do you do are you a cafe
restaurant or
you wanting to be a wine bar or I know
you heard you said it was sort of like
to go a bit more continental but if
upstairs is purely for smoking do they
have food up there that sort of thing
sure I mean we operate through it's a
cafe
so it's a free story opening the top
floor is the residential which we have
tenants in there and the second floor is
the bar which is known as bar 14 and
then the bottom floor is the cafe which
we are currently in the process of
introducing and Italian we have an
Italian chef who's arrived so we're
going to start serving Italian dishes
ground floor and how close are you to
residential neighbors then you mentioned
there was a roof but you said there was
nobody in it if I got that correct or
not so are there any neighbors living
close proximity to the best of my
knowledge I believe from the outlook of
the terrace or to the right hand side
two buildings down there is a
residential property there which I
believe was one of the objectives of
Irish house and there are on the further
side of the terrace there are some again
residents living there which we do have
a good relationship with and have you
engaged with the people who are
obviously unhappy at the moment have you
engaged with them at all have you been
round to see them if they've been to see
you know there has been nothing but
you've obviously been aware there's been
wrong yeah okay thank you
I'm interested to know why you feel to
open until one o'clock would be
beneficial to your business the primary
reason for that is is our customers were
saying ah I wish you open open long open
longer open longer
in order to pursue that we par
application for it
can I follow on with that because these
questions prompt questions don't know
we're sort of the local pub is that
frequented until later hours or do you
know or do people come from there to
your establishment I mean naturally
being a fairly small town we do have
customers either end and they're ours
I'm not aware of that they're opening
all of their licensing hours I'm not
aware no but did they come do you know
whether people I mean I'm trying to work
out whether you're primarily a cafe or a
drinking establishment and you know do
they come from there to follow on if you
see what I mean and do you get the
younger generation this gentleman has
kindly told us his age which is young as
far as I'm concerned you know do you get
a mix of people in there on this yes we
do we do get a mixture of it anything
ranging from 18 to I mean they come from
the pub to us there's a large hotel for
the oak smear that the people from from
far away come and then they want you
know dining sorry a cocktail and then
they come to us and with regard to young
people if you're having food in the
establishment is there anything that you
know they have to come in with family to
eat and they're allowed to sit and have
I don't know I don't know whether more
sitting rules are for younger people but
is it an obligatory thing that they
would have a meal and then drink or is
it just straight to the bar I mean
obviously young people you couldn't
allow him it's it's seen as two
different completely different I mean
the CAF is called cafe and then the bar
is is known as bar 14 so there there's I
mean our cafe customers won't have have
their meal and then come up to the bar
it's basically following up what Casey
Guthrie was saying earlier you mentioned
that you serve food between upstate four
o'clock yet you just so you've taken on
an Italian chef so we are you have you
plans to sort of cook in the evenings as
well for evening meals you know we as
well because what we did operate as was
an all-day breakfast so we're looking to
maybe stop the breakfast around about
the 12 p.m. mark and then introduce the
the Italian food so with that go on it's
the evening also we're still finish it
four o'clock currently where we there
aren't any plans to to extend that after
4:00 well I think we've are sufficient
questions haven't we so I think now if
you would like to sum up and you are the
person that has the final say and to
really give us full details of your
business and how you see it going
forward and what you've heard today so
if you like to tell us your final
statements thank you sure as I
previously mentioned I I feel as if we
are an important asset to the community
and to the local residents and again on
multiple occasions they have said to us
that they feel like they're abroad again
because of the service that we offer the
cocktails that whether it's a slice of
apple on a cocktail glass you know with
some lights flashing underneath it is
something that they only experience
abroad and it gives us great joy to be
able to offer our customers that and it
has saddened me that that we have had
objections especially on the nuisance I
mean me personally I see that the
resident says how would I feel if I was
living there and if that directly come
to us regarding whether it's noise and
again without coming to this extent that
it would have been dealt with
it's my previous example the eve the
blinds the customer felt as if people
were looking down on a house and lovely
lady a good customer of ours so
we all offered some also ordered some
blinds to to Carrefour area and then
obviously that situation was it was
dealt with and me being one to one
involved with the business I'm there
every day and any problems I are dealt
with immediately the extension of hours
sorry the extension of our hours our
field will just be able to bear offer
and have happier customers thank you
I've come to the point where we would
now close the session and we will go
into our debate so if we can kindly ask
you to leave come the officers
you
so we'll ask our legal adviser to read
out the decision of the committee thank
you thank you
the committee members have considered
your application very carefully and also
considered the representations made in
response to your application they are
going to grant a variation to your
license but it's not going to be exactly
as you apply for they do consider there
is a potential for public nuisance given
that the setting of your establishment
and in the environment so what they are
going to do they're going to amend the
hours but from Sunday to Thursday the
supply of alcohol will be to 1130 each
night with a closing time of midnight
the Friday and Saturday hours are as
applied for so you have till midnight 30
on those nights and closing time of 1:00
a.m. there is a additional condition
granted in respect of the the terrace as
the the members considered valleys a
sensitive area for for causing public
nuisance late at night and the
additional condition is that the outside
Terrace shall not be used for licensable
purposes and drinking after 11:30 p.m.
each night so that would mean that
customers will have to come in at 11:30
access is still granted after that time
for for smoking but obviously if they're
not taking drinks with them they're less
likely to be out there for any length of
time or will come back and that madness
the thinking of the members on that and
there is a an amendment to one of your
conditions under the Prevention of
public nuisance and the condition that
you had put in was that the sale and
consumption of alcohol shall cease by
100 hours or one yet when I am removed
the words sale and so it shall now read
the consumption of alcohol shall cease
by 1 a.m.
and that applies to Saturday and Sunday
mornings and another similar condition
is included that the cell sorry the
consumption of alcohol shall cease by
midnight on Thursday on Monday to
Thursday mornings so just tighten up did
the sound was was causing confusing
because it was in a slight conflict with
what she had applied for and that's as
granted that's the decision of the
subcommittee subcommittee there is a
right of appeal against the the decision
or any of the conditions that you're not
happy with and that might have appeal
must be made to the magistrate's court
within 21 days of receiving written
confirmation of this decision that's it
thank you very much for your
presentations and so the meeting is now
closed thank you very much everybody
thank you
[Applause]